joining us right now for a closer look
at what you need to know about the
economy is cbs news business analyst
jill schlesinger as i like to call her
dollar dollar jill y'all so uh
jill what's behind the rise in recent
sales well i think it's a couple of
things first of all we know prices are
higher so inflation actually contributes
to this big number that we got in
october however even when we inflation
adjust retail sales we're actually at
pre-pandemic levels so it's really
interesting to note that people have
higher wages they've been sitting on
this ample mound of savings and they do
want to get a jump on the holiday season
because of these supply chain issues so
put it together it was a very strong
report for october now as we saw in meg
oliver's piece even though there's a
boost in sales there's still a shortage
of laborers what's going on well this is
especially true with small to
medium-sized businesses and we've seen
these labor shortages persist it started
with just a fear of the virus i was fair
fearful for myself i'm fearful for
someone in my family right child care
issues also and then on top of that i
think there's been a real reassessment
of what's important to me do i want to
take a job with lousy pay and lousy
benefits and of course a ton of early
retirements put it that together and man
it is tough to hire people you see how
much they have to pay to get someone in
the door for all of those that are
sitting at home saying what do i need to
know before i start my holiday shopping
what do you tell them um we did this
first we mentioned this in september i
looked this up on september 7th we
talked about on this show that you were
going to have to start your holiday
season early and yes that is true also
don't expect huge sales because i don't
think that's going to take place make
sure you don't blow through your budget
of course and finally maybe we take this
period and we say remember the grinch at
the end of the grid you stole christmas
and the grinch's heart grew three times
and he found the true meaning of
christmas maybe we got to get back to
that a little bit and not do the
consumerism thing so much still you're
the best